[Music]
all right who used to watch the TV show
when they were a kids Gladiators
American Gladiator American Gladiators
right that onean gladiator yeah hell
yeah everybody remember how it went down
like yeah like you have like these
challenges you have to run shoot like
balls and then you get to the end and
then some guy [__] body slam I heard
those dudes got paid nothing really
really I heard those dudes got
documentary about it right now I think
so but the show is actually back no do
they got the names though laser turbo I
have I have a friend that was on the the
first reboot cuz they they they did it
back in the back day and then they had a
second one but I don't know if she's on
this new new one do they have the names
though yeah I forgot what her name was
giant
electric electric yeah I like that I can
try and look up all their names Thunder
I think her name was either Thunder or
like Phoenix or something Malibu no
who's Malibu he's like the surfer guy
he's like a surfer Gladiator who guy
jacked yeah and he had a whole character
they have to wear the same like looking
like Captain America yeah Wonder Woman
they were like they were like pro
wrestler vibe after a while they had
like whole like Back stories I I like
those shows that are like that or even
like pros versus Joe's cuz you know
there's all these like pros versus Joe's
keyboard Warriors that aren't even like
pre-existing to internet where just like
they watch it like ah why doesn't he do
this like go up against someone that's
actually professional at something
though remember that show they used to
do called Bully Beatdown yeah yeah wait
was that Joe Rogan no that was Mayhem
Miller they would get like these like
the whole premise was like I'm getting
bullied by this guy and then they would
like do a whole yeah they do a whole
montage of him being a [__] he's
like he takes money from me and and he's
trying to make out my T everyone pays me
respect he always says weird things to
my mom or whatever and he's like oh
don't worry we'll kick his [__] ass
and then they'll pretty much fight him
they'll literally do like a Gra grapping
round where they just keep tapping the
dude out and they'll get a professional
MMA fighter to beat this [__] out of
this dude and then they'll do like a
kickboxing round and then they'll do
like a grapping and beat the [__] out of
this dude it it what happened to that
show why would they why would the bully
sign up for that I think they're really
that delusional yeah it's TI you know
there's dudes at the bar they think they
could [__] everyone up even MMA fighters
they just go like dude I [__] anybody
when I when I [__] get angry I just
see red like those kind of guys you know
it's like but I'm crazy like in the
streets there's like no [__] rules
like when I turn it on dude you know
what the [__] coming I love those guys
how do you do that yeah that [__] is
real bro real those guys that's who we
really are now bre it he lives see that
there it is we are about that want you
to tell Jenny what she missed out
on so these guys names this is actually
a UK bring back of the Gladiator oh God
damn it okay I don't want to see [__]
[__] gentlemen yeah what are they
going to play chess bu of lads their
names are Ace Amazon Apollo aena Atlas
battle axe bionic battle a oh battle axe
better be some like wife something
like Cobra Comet they have ball and
chain ROM Electro Dynamite Electro
Enigma Falcon fire flame fox fire and
Flame good luck getting all those ATS
for Instagram giant gold Goliath
and [__] Predator I want to see some big
ass mother or they look like the dudes
that guard the [__] Buckingham Palace
yeah all of them look like that yeah and
they don't talk with no sleeves on their
mouth and they just go no I want to see
some like do you know you guys know
Eddie holl he's a English English strong
man I want to see some Eddie Hall
looking [__] dude Eddie Hall's
huge I always felt like American
Gladiator is one of those shows that you
classify under the European mind cannot
comprehend this like you know American
Pride it was so like like Turned Up and
tuned out that like you would think like
European people wouldn't [__] buy it
here they are yeah cuz like was
professional wrestling being in the UK
that's a nice photo oh yeah they look
pretty athletic looking those Leo oh
it's not American look [__] huge too
looks like [__] Drago rocking yo look
at her they look AI dude
damn I hope it's cheesy though because
that's why Gladiators was good it was do
you guys remember like it was so
purposely cheesy if they Tred to do it
British humor where it's all [__] dry
yeah what are you supposed to do with
that bangers and mash dude that's all I
know about the I thought it was all for
us like our age like elementary school
kids it it felt like that era they made
so much content for kids yeah I mean it
was it was the best feeling to like take
like your [__] Hugging Pillows as a
kid and pretend you're on like some
[__] line with your cousins or some
[__] and try to see who can get knocked
really watch it now though I don't even
know I would watch the old episodes now
I have retro viw the [__] out of it I
have never seen it as an adult I want to
see them bring Pros versus Joe's back
that's what I want to see I I think I
would yeah I would I would like some but
isn't it like Ninja Warrior though where
PE regular people just try to do the
thing and then [__] um the they get
[__] up by Turbo or what the human
element is awesome cuz ninja war is just
you versus the obstacle course having
like a boss at the end that whoops your
ass is [__] nja war is different
because it was only like that in the
beginning now everyone trains
specifically for that you ever see the
[__] the monkey do the ninja word oh
yeah a chimp like a real monkey a real
chimp does the whole thing she does it
so easy smashes it and then it's like
all the comments are like oh you forget
that this entire show makes humans do
what chimps do all the time wow rip
someone's face off at the
end now the chimp does it and the chimp
does it so [__] easy and at the end
he just sits there like banana please
hits the [__] red
button banana
please you know what TV show I just
started watching for the first time ever
uh cuz I was trying to get my alone fix
right oh I like alone bro yeah I love
alone so but I finished every [__]
season so I was like me and Ne were like
I Heard naked in a phrase kind of tight
it's kind of fun have you guys ever seen
nak we talked about it here before loves
it though does he what does he love
about it the butt cheeks I don't know
but he always talks about it that is a
really hilarious like component to the
entire show have you seen cuz there's
guys and grow butt cheeks a lot of butt
cheeks yeah and it's like oh half the
times too one of the pairings like one
of the person in the pairings is like
Married with Children so you're always
just like that's funny like this person
submit they're like I need to prove that
I can do this but like butt naked with a
stranger for 21 days it's like go home
dude and it's raining or freezing
they're like spooning cuz it has to be
like skin- to skin contact in order to
stay warm and you're just like that's
funny I remember there was one episode
of naked afraid that I saw where it was
like this white dude he's like a
military guy and some like hippie chick
and they go on the island and the dude
gets sunburned in the first day like
terribly bro like medically like oh dude
this guy may not make it and he just
like under the he's under a shade and
she's doing all the [__] work and
he's just like ah my sunburns and it's
like dude this is [__] up this is so
[__] up he he was like useless for the
whole show he couldn't do anything I saw
I saw this one show on I think you're
allowed to bring like eight or 10 items
have you guys seen it alone is that
alone yeah you get to bring like eight
or 10 items they drop you off and I
think this one was like Alaska or
something and then this guy like he has
OCD like me so he was like I'm going to
first build a shelter and he's building
like straight up Lincoln Log Cabin Stu
sick right yeah and then but after the
first day he's like oh I feel so weak I
shouldn't have done that only Built one
side then he ends up quitting yeah yeah
that should happen I have no food like I
I should have Hunted
first that's just so funny yeah cuz it's
like so much of like your the whole game
of alone is like how well you can manage
your energy throughout the day yeah and
he was just spending time building
perfect notches of logs and he's like oh
I'm so hungry now there was one guy well
this happens a lot on alone and that's
like the other side of it is like once
you make it through all the like
necessities of like yeah having food
shelter water that he's just like I
missed my family like I'm like this is
bad I hate it when that [__] happens
dude and then they leave and you're like
oh [__] that's be like super hardcore D
everything right hunt really well and
stuff and then even have like a [__]
cache of food and they're like I'm just
thinking about my my daughters though
and then you're like this [__] a
screw your da you're [__] missing
them grow up you dumb ass yeah the
entire the entire first half though
they're like like if I win this half a
million dollars I can like you know get
them through school or or let them live
their dream a lot too though yeah so you
know it's like all I got to do is last 3
months and get them blah blah but then
halfway through they're like yeah but
then I'm missing them grow up and it's
like okay but what happened what
happened to to the half a million
dollars yeah that you wanted to provide
for them cuz at that point it's only a
matter of time before they make I want
to see a show like a survival show where
they take the nature expert dude and
they trade spots with the skid row guy
and they see who survives longer in each
other's environment I think the roll guy
wins dude that's what I'm saying yeah
but he doesn't have crack
oh [__] yeah he's going to withdrawal
symtoms bring 10 10 items but then but
then his withdrawal CRA his withdrawal
is racing this guy's brand new
addiction
like and they got different sets of
predators
now pine cones never made me feel like
this he's trying to make synthetic
drunks in the
forest